bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat le 11 novembre dernier lors de son
discours au pied de l'arc de triomphe
nicolas sarkozy annoncé son souhait de
voir évoluer les cérémonies
commémoratives de l'armistice de 1918
le président souhaitait qu en ce jour du
11 novembre ne soit plus seulement
commémorer que les morts de la première
guerre mondiale
mais tous les morts pour la france il a
d'ailleurs ce jour-là annoncé qu'un
projet de loi serait déposé en ce sens
et c'est justement ce texte qui est
examinée cet après midi par le sénat un
texte déjà voté le 11 janvier par
l'assemblée nationale mais un texte
complété par la commission du sénat qui
a adopté à l'unanimité un amendement
précisant que cet hommage ne doit pas se
substituer aux autres journée de
commémoration nationale manière pour le
sénat d'apaiser les craintes de
certaines associations d'anciens
combattants tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle poursuivre l'examen de ce
texte
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le 21 juin dernier
j'ai exprimé mon émotion après la mort
d'un soldat qui appartenaient au 1er
régiment de chasseurs parachutistes basé
à pamiers une nouvelle fois je veux
saluer ici la mémoire au nom du sénat de
quatre soldats morts en afghanistan
l'adjudant chef fabien vinh âgé de 43
ans et père d'un enfant
l'adjudant chef denis est un âgé de 45
ans et père de deux enfants du 93e
régiment d'artillerie de montagne
le sergent-chef vilaine
simonov âgé de 34 ans et père d'un
enfant
le brigadier-chef geoffrey beau mais là
âgé de 27 ans et père d'un enfant du 2e
régiment étranger de génie désarmés ils
ont été lâchement simon au nom du sénat
tout entier j'assure à leur famille à
leurs proches
toute notre compassion attristé je leur
présente nos condoléances ainsi qu'aux
chefs de corps officiers sous-officiers
et soldats engagés dans ce pays depuis
plus de dix ans une cérémonie s'est
déroulée aux invalides tout à l'heure
nous pensons également aux quinze autres
soldats blessés dont huit graves
grièvement
12 ayant été rapatriés depuis le début
du déploiement de la coalition
internationale
quatre-vingt deux militaires français
ont au total perdu la vie avec ces
sacrifice ultime
c'est un lourd tribut que les militaires
ont payé au service de la paix
n'oublions pas à côté de nos soldats
le rôle de nos coopérants civils et
l'importance de la coopération
parlementaire noué entre notre assemblée
et la deuxième chambre
à
j'adresse au nom de notre assemblée ou
trois mille six cents soldats français
un message de soutien dans leur mission
difficile
je veux exprimer avec émotion et respect
aux soldats disparus à leurs familles
la reconnaissance du sénat de la
république allez voir de ces quatre
soldats je vous proposerai après que
monsieur le ministre se soit exprimé je
vous proposerai mes chers collègues
d'observer un moment de recueillement ce
ministre merci monsieur le président
permettez moi aussi peut penser bien sûr
nos quatre soldats qui ont été lâchement
assassinés comme vous venez de le dire
monsieur le président ainsi qu'au 15 de
leurs frères qui ont été blessés
aujourd'hui la france entière portent
leur deuil
car à très heureux c'est la france qui
est touché je vous le dire à leurs
familles combien je partage leur peine
combien je sais ce que signifie la perte
d'un fils ou d'un frère qu'elle soit
assurer de notre soutien qu'elle soit
assuré aussi qu'ils sont morts dans
l'accomplissement de leur devoir ils
sont morts parce qu'ils étaient porteurs
des valeurs de la france qui voulait
faire partager et que l'on veut toujours
faire partager au peuple afghan
la paix la liberté et la démocratie
chers collègues je vous demande observé
une minute de silence en mémoire de nos
soldats morts en afghanistan
je vous remercie
je vais suspendant la séance pour de
tricot instant l'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion du projet de loi adopté
par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
fixant 11 novembre la commémoration de
tous les morts pour la france dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur marc laffineur secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de la défense
et des anciens combattants
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
il ne revient l'honneur de vous
présenter le projet de loi fixant au 11
novembre la commémoration de tous les
morts pour la france
ce projet de loi avait été annoncée par
le président de la république le 11
novembre dernier
dans le discours qu'il avait prononcé
sous l'arc de triomphe
ce jour-là il rendait hommage à
l'ensemble des morts pour la france tout
en commémorant bien sûr la fin de la
grande guerre il s'engageait dans le
même temps à pérenniser cette approche
nouvelle des cérémonies du 11 novembre
aujourd'hui sa parole est en passe
d'être tenus à la satisfaction des
principales associations d'anciens
combattants des familles ou encore des
militaires d'actes et nous le devons
aussi à votre mobilisation
vous savez tous combien les questions de
mémoire importe à la cohésion de notre
société
je dirais même à sa dignité
c'est pourquoi elles ne peuvent être
cantonné à des clivages partisans
votre implication soutenue démontrent
qu'elles jouent pleinement leur rôle
fédérateur
l'examen du projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale cet exemplaire il en a été de
même ici lors du passage en commission
et je vous en remercie vivement cette
évolution était nécessaire et plus
encore notre devoir de citoyen notre
devoir républicain nous l'imposé elle
vise donc à renforcer la symbolique du
11 novembre
désormais jour anniversaire de
l'armistice de 1918 et de commémoration
annuelle de la victoire d' de la paix où
il est rendu hommage
à tous les morts pour la france cette
évolution tient à deux raisons
principales la première c'est la
disparition du dernier poilu en 2011 et
la proche du centenaire de la grande
guerre pour que l'héritage historique de
la première guerre mondiale soit
préservée pour que ces enseignements
continue de nous guider de se
transmettre pour que son centenaire soit
un grand moment d'unité nationale il
fallait une approche renouvelée des
commémorations la seconde raison c'est
la nécessité d'honorer la quatrième
génération du feu celle ci n'a pas moins
mérité de la nation que les générations
qui l'ont précédé les théâtres
d'opération se sont multipliées exigeant
de nos soldats
un engagement plein et entier au péril
de leur vie
depuis la fin de la guerre d'algérie ce
sont plus de 600 militaires qui sont
morts pour la france
les événements tragiques de vendredi
nous l'ont rappelé douloureusement leur
sacrifice mérite tout autant que celui
de leurs aînés que l'on se souvienne
échos souvenir soit associé respect et
reconnaissance
or le calendrier républicain ne
permettaient pas jusqu'à l'art de rendre
la quatrième de rendre à la quatrième
génération du feu l'hommage qui lui est
dû il n'était cependant pas question de
créer une journée commémorative
spécifique la commission kaspi l'avait
souligné sue été fragmenté davantage
notre mémoire collective prendre le
risque de la division et finalement de
louis l'esprit nouveau des
commémorations du 11 novembre permet de
pallier le manque tout en appelant à
l'unité associer l'ensemble des
générations du feu
c'est en effet souligné les valeurs
qu'elles ont en commun ce sens de
l'engagement qui va jusqu'au sacrifice
ultime
c'est aussi rappelé
que le combat pour la france pour la
liberté la démocratie est un combat qui
traverse l'histoire et ne sera jamais
dépassé nous l'avons vu ces derniers
mois en libye et en côte d'ivoire
nos armées ont mis leur
professionnalisme leur courage et leur
réactivité au profit de l'aspiration des
peuples à la liberté et à la démocratie
en afghanistan
elle se mobilise tout autant contre
l'obscurantisme et pour la paix si les
succès remportés
si les progrès réalisés font notre
fierté nous le devons à l'engagement
d'hommes et de femmes qui acceptent de
risquer leur vie pour une cause qui les
dépasse parce que leur combat sont
dignes de ceux de leurs aînés
la filiation entre les générations du
feu sera désormais célébrée chaque 11
novembre ainsi plus un mort pour la
france plus un sacrifice ne sera menacé
par l'oubli parce qu'il ne peut être
associée à une journée particulière de
notre calendrier républicain
je rappelle que cette évolution ne remet
absolument pas en cause les autres dates
commémoratives
il n'est pas question d'en supprimer ou
de les hiérarchiser
le président de la république en a pris
l'engagement le 11 novembre dernier les
autres conflits seconde guerre mondiale
indochine correa jerry les autres
événements marquants de notre histoire
du 20e siècle
l'appel du 18 juin l'hommage aux harkis
conserveront leurs journées nationales
de même
l'héritage historique de la grande
guerre continuera d'être honoré le 11
novembre
le texte est clair le 11 novembre
demeure le jour anniversaire de
l'armistice de 1918
et puisqu'il prend la forme d'une loi
autonome il ne modifie en rien la loi de
celle ci reste l'acte de reconnaissance
et de mémoire des seuls soldats morts au
cours de la grande guerre
j'ajouterai que ce projet de loi
renforce davantage encore la profondeur
historique du 11 novembre la commission
kaspi avait souligné son caractère
fédérateur
je le cite le 11 novembre apparaît dans
le souvenir collectif des français comme
la manifestation la plus emblématique
d'hommage aux combattants morts pour la
patrie
la grande guerre fut en effet un moment
d'unité nationale comme il en existe peu
dans notre histoire unités dans
l'horreur mais ie 6 unités dans la
victoire
elle est à l'image de l'unité qui doit
prévaloir en matière de mémoire unité
entre générations du feu et unité de la
nation dans l'hommage aussi se souvenir
fondateur du 20e siècle est il à même de
porter le renouveau de notre mémoire
collective au 21e siècle il se prête à
une symbolique renforcée à une solennité
accrue il invite à méditer le sens de
notre histoire nationale que l'on doit
d'abord aux morts pour la france
civils et militaires dans le même esprit
le gouvernement appuyé lors de l'examen
du texte en commission à l'assemblée
nationale l'amendement visant à rendre
obligatoire l'inscription des morts pour
la france sur les monuments aux morts
cet amendement constitue dans le texte
qui vous est présentée l'article 2
jusqu'à présent l'inscription était
laissée à la discrétion des mères
tous les morts pour la france sans
exception pourront désormais recevoir
cet hommage de la nation
c'est un symbole fort me semble-t-il que
de graver ainsi leur nom dans le marbre
et c'est particulièrement important pour
le deuil et la mémoire des familles
je rappelle également que le
gouvernement soutiendra la construction
d'un monument dédié aux soldats morts en
opérations extérieures
ce projet qui repose sur une coopération
productive avec la ville de paris vise
lui aussi à pérenniser la reconnaissance
de la nation envers la quatrième
génération du feu mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
c'est l'honneur d'un grand peuple de
respecter ces soldats et d'honorer ceux
qui sont morts pour le défendre
ces mots prononcés par le président la
république le 11 novembre dernier
traduisent l'esprit du texte qui vous
est présentée aujourd'hui c'est parce
que la france se fait une certaine idée
de sa vocation dans le monde parce qu
elle se réclame de valeurs universelles
et qu'elle se donne les moyens de les
défendre
qu'elle se doit d'être exemplaire dans
la reconnaissance qu'elle porte à ses
soldats
chacun d'entre nous doit sa liberté à
ceux qui sont tombés sous les drapeaux
chacun d'entre nous doit sa dignité à
ceux qui acceptent de défendre nos
valeurs par les armes
ce projet de loi nous invite à ne jamais
l'oublier c'est pourquoi je vous engage
bien sûr à lui apporter votre vote
oui monsieur le ministre
la discussion générale la parole est un
monsieur marcel pierre cléach rapporteur
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et d'essence armée vers la
parole monsieur rapporteur
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues le projet de loi
soumis à votre examen à la suite de son
adoption par votre commission fixe au 11
novembre la commémoration de tous les
morts pour la france
l'objectif est de rassembler dans un
même hommage annuel
tous les morts pour la france quelles
que soient les situations personnelles
quel que soit leur statut quelle que
soit la localisation des conflits sur le
territoire national ou sur des
territoires extérieurs
quelle que soit la génération du feu à
laquelle ils appartiennent d'abord ceux
des conflits du passé de la grande
guerre la plus meurtrière avec ses 1
million 400 mille morts
bien sûr mais aussi des conflits
postérieurs comme la seconde guerre
mondiale soldats et résistants et des
guerres d'indochine et d'algérie
et pourquoi pas dans notre coeur ceux de
conflits antérieurs qui ont forgé notre
nation comment ai-je pu repart et xemple
ceux de valmy et même ceux des guerres
que nous avons oublié et dont il nous
faut pour nous souvenir ouvrir un livre
d'histoire ce ensuite des conflits du
présent ceux des opérations extérieures
et je pense bien entendu à nos
militaires tombés en afghanistan
auxquels le sénat vient de rendre
hommage enfin ce qui hélas tomberont de
mal tous ont eu la force le courage
l'abnégation de servir leur patrie
jusqu'au sacrifice suprême
tous ont eu la volonté de servir la
république et ses valeurs
tous morts pour la france il ne s'agit
donc non pas d'honorer les guerres mais
n'aurait les morts il ne s'agit pas de
créer une commémoration unique
il s'agit de créer une commémoration
commune le président de la république a
bien pris soin de préciser je le cite
qu'il soit bien clair qu'aucune
commémoration ne sera supprimé et qu'il
s'agit seulement de donner plus de
solennité encore 11 novembre alors que
tous les témoins ont disparu cette
assurance a été rappelé à de nombreuses
reprises notamment
par vous monsieur le ministre lors des
entretiens et échanges que vous avez eue
avec des associations d'anciens
combattants lors de l'examen du projet
de loi l'assemblée nationale et à
l'instant même ici au sénat si un
certain nombre d'entre elles ont
manifesté très vite leur adhésion à ce
projet qui allait dans le sens de leurs
réflexions d'autres d'autres
associations ont émis des craintes que
cela préfigure l'instauration d'un
mémorial day journée unique du souvenir
à la française et conduisent à l'abandon
progressif des autres commémorations
nationales
il est important et cela a été rappelé
en commission de maintenir la
singularité de ces commémorations
outre l'attachement des anciens
combattants à la perpétuation du
souvenir des combats qui l'ont mené et
des camarades qui ont perdu leur vie les
spécificités de chaque conflit doivent
être prises en considération pour en
faire connaître les caractéristiques
essentielles parfois avec des
appréciations différentes qui reflète la
pluralité des mémoires de ceux qui les
ont vécus elle donne aussi l'occasion
renouvelé chaque année de faire oeuvre
enseignante oeuvre d'histoire peuvent re
d'instruction civique et de patriotisme
au profit notamment des jeunes
générations
c'est pourquoi après une discussion très
ouverte
marqué par une volonté d'écouté de
dialogue à laquelle je vous remercie
monsieur le président de la commission
et vous monsieur le ministre d'avoir
contribué
votre commission a souhaité formaliser
cet engagement en votant un amendement
de notre collègue à la mairie et du
groupe socialiste il précise il précise
que cet hommage ne se substitue pas aux
autres journée de commémoration
nationale
s'agissant de la date retenue pour cette
commémoration de tous les morts pour la
france
le choix du 11 novembre semble le
meilleur
cette date reste en effet en crée dans
la mémoire collective comme la
manifestation la plus emblématique
d'hommage aux combattants morts pour la
patrie
elle est la date de commémoration des
morts de la guerre
qui a engagé le plus de combattants et
fut la plus meurtrière
c'est d'ailleurs à l'occasion de cette
guerre que fut instituée par la loi du 2
juillet 1915 la mention mort pour la
france elle est aussi et peut-être
surtout une commémoration de l'unité
nationale autour de la défense de la
patrie et de la république
la commémoration d'une nation retrouver
dans l'épreuve qui a su faire preuve de
cohésion malgré celles malgré ses
divisions celle de l'union sacrée elle
n'a jamais été contestée ni lors de son
instauration
ni depuis elle englobe en outre la
mémoire d'autres événements à commencer
par le sursaut patriotique des étudiants
et lycéens parisiens qui convergent vers
l'arc de triomphe le 11 novembre 1940
malgré l'interdiction de l'occupant et
qui sera considérée comme l'un des
premiers actes de la résistance jusqu
aux hommages rendus régulièrement aux
forces engagées dans les différents
conflits
la dernière en date le 11 novembre 2011
aux unités engagées en côte d'ivoire en
afghanistan et en libye
si au cours du 14 juillet par le défilé
militaire
ce sont nos armes et qui rendent hommage
à la république le 11 novembre et on
constitue en quelque sorte le pendant la
nation rend hommage à ceux de ses
enfants qui sont morts pour la défense
de son territoire et de ses valeurs le
projet de loi initial a été complété par
l'assemblée nationale pour rendre
obligatoire l'inscription des morts pour
la france sur les monuments aux morts
des communes et organise les demandes
d'inscription ceci permettra d'inscrire
notamment les militaires morts pour la
france en opérations extérieures au delà
de l'hommage collectif annuel de la
nation la mémoire de chaque compte de
chacun d'eux sera ainsi conservé par
cette inscription
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à l'image
de votre commission qui a voté ce projet
à unanimité
je souhaiterais que nous soyons le plus
nombreux possible à nous rassembler pour
commémorer le souvenir
de ceux qui ont donné leur vie pour
notre pays et pour les valeurs qu'il
défend
ce serait un beau témoignage non
seulement pour ceux que nous honorons
chaque année mais aussi pour marquer
notre reconnaissance à ceux qui sur des
théâtres d'opérations extérieures
connaissent la dure réalité de la guerre
et enfin pour nos concitoyens qu'ils
attendent de la représentation nationale
l'expression de son unité autour des
valeurs essentielles de la république en
la circonstance
légiférer c'est d'une certaine manière
commémorer c'est aussi quelle que soit
notre point de vue sur les conflits
passés ou en cours
reconnaître la valeur du sacrifice de
nos enfants et le caractère sacré de
leur vie l'ancien combattant d'algérie
que je suis a été honoré de vous
présenter ce texte je vous demande mes
chers collègues de m'accompagner dans
cette démarche d'union en hommage à nos
morts pour la france
démarche qu'attendent la quasi totalité
des associations d'anciens combattants
démarche qui honore le sénat je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de discussions générales la parole
et tamada michelle demessine
sa couche et le coup venir de l'autre
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la mort
dans des circonstances tragiques de
quatre de nos soldats en afghanistan
donne une signification toute
particulière au projet de loi que nous
examinons cet après midi il nous
rappelle qu'un soldat français envoyés
par le gouvernement de la république
meurt toujours pour la france
j'ai une pensée particulière pour la
douleur des familles de ces hommes qui
ont été lâchement abattus alors qu'ils
étaient venus dans ce pays avec la
conviction de défendre des valeurs
universelles dans de telles
circonstances l'examen de ce projet de
loi assisterez à ce qu'il soit
consensuel méfions-nous cependant de ces
lois adoptées sous le coup de l'émotion
j'éprouve en effet quelques réticences
aux appels au rassemblement à l'union
nationale aux bons sentiments quand ils
sont lancés en temps de crise est en
période électorale
pourtant il pourrait sembler naturel et
logique de faire évoluer les cérémonies
anniversaire de l'armistice de 1918
afin d'éviter que la commémoration du 11
novembre ne s'effrite mais quelle
urgence y at il donc à légiférer sur
l'organisation et la signification de
ces cérémonies dix mois avant les
prochaines commémorations et deux ans
avant le centenaire de la guerre de 14
cette précipitation autorise vraiment à
penser que ce texte traduit
implicitement la volonté du président de
la république d'ajouter cette profonde
modification de nos traditions à
l'édifice de l'histoire nationale avant
la fin de son quinquennat comme sur
d'autres sujets tout aussi important
cette décision sans l'électoralisme car
il s'agit à l'évidence de donner
satisfaction à une certaine partie de
nos concitoyens
sensible à ces questions avant
l'élection présidentielle
cette façon empressé précipité de
transformer la signification d'une
grande commémoration nationale
laisse la désagréable impression que le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas en tout cas
un véritable débat sur la politique de
mémoire légiférer sereinement sur le
sens à donner aux manifestations du
souvenir aurait nécessité de débattre
publiquement avec l'ensemble de la
société plus longuement et de manière
plus approfondie se dire ce débat aurait
pourtant tout sa raison d'être
comme je viens de le dire puisqu'il
permettrait d'évoquer temps deux
périodes souvent douloureux de notre
histoire et dont les causes et la
signification sont différentes et je
puis en témoigner particulièrement
venant d'une région où les centièmes ou
les centaines de cimetières militaires
de toutes les nationalités jalonnent le
territoire sur des centaines de
kilomètres et évoque ainsi la louvre de
porter des trois des traces de la même
des traces de la mémoire de ses
souffrances
dans ces conditions la décision du
président de la république fixée au 11
novembre la commémoration de tous les
morts pour la france
pour donner plus de solennité à cesser
cérémonie comme vous le suggérez
monsieur le ministre et permettre
d'accueillir les soldats tombés en
opérations extérieures en reliant par le
souvenir toutes les générations du feu
cette décision n'est pas notre avis à la
hauteur des valeurs qu'elle pourrait
ainsi mettre en cause dans le cours de
sa discussion l'assemblée nationale a
renforcé l'obligation d'inscrire leur
nom sur les monuments aux morts de nos
communes et notre commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense a à
juste titre pour dissiper tout
malentendu clairement ajouté à la loi
que cet hommage transformer ne se
substituait pas subtilité pas aux autres
journée de commémoration nationale mais
pourtant des questions importantes
surgissent et des problèmes de fond
n'ont pas été clairement tranchée par
les débats à l'assemblée nationale dans
notre commission car le diable se cache
dans les détails
la modification du caractère mémorial de
la commémoration du 11 novembre en
rendant hommage à l'ensemble des morts
pour la france et en amalgamant de fait
les dates et les conflits risque
d'accréditer les
et qu'au final peu importe les raisons
pour lesquelles des militaires et des
civils ont perdu la vie et en même temps
de faire perdre sa spécificité à cette
commémoration est ce le meilleur moyen
de faire vivre le devoir de mémoire et
d'entretenir le souvenir
la première guerre mondiale et par le
drame qu'elle a représenté un élément
fondateur du siècle dernier
sa dimension est aussi historique par le
nombre d'états qui ont été engagées dans
son conflit sa dimension inédite
c'est également d'avoir redessiner la
carte de l'europe est profondément
influencé l'histoire géopolitique du 20e
siècle
mais le 11 au 20 doit peut-être avant
tout rester l'évocation de ce terrible
carnage qui a touché toutes les familles
françaises et fait plus de 10 millions
de morts de toutes nationalités dont un
million et demi de jeunes français si
bien dépeints dans le feu d'henri
barbusse de ce conflit particulier nous
devons continuer de tirer les
enseignements
il ya donc un grand risque en confondant
les mémoires et les événements en
amalgamant des engagements multiples qui
n'ont pas la même portée historique et
humaine de tous fondre dans une même
condamnation abstraite de la guerre qui
en play qui empêche de réfléchir sur les
causes on ne distingue en plus les
choses en confondant les conflits on
aboutit à une vision aseptisée de
l'histoire de la mémoire collective qui
ne permet plus de comprendre le passé et
de construire lucidement l'avenir je ne
remets bien sûr nous manque aux à forte
légitimité de la mention mort pour la
france porté sur les actes de décès un
soldat qui était envoyé par le
gouvernement de la république est
toujours tuer au nom de la france
en revanche je conteste l'idée que tous
les conflits soit de même nature et qui
plus est et puisse être être mis sur le
même plan tous les conflits dans lequel
la france a été engagées n'ont pas
toujours délivré le même message de
défense de nos valeurs et notre sécurité
à l'extérieur des frontières et je doute
vraiment que ce soit ce message qui
était est délivré
et par le corps expéditionnaire envoyé
en indochine par le bataillon français
qui a combattu en corée dans les années
50 ou bien encore lors de la période de
la des locaux l'eau nisation autant nous
sommes d'accord pour rendre un hommage
particulier aux soldats qui dans ce que
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les opérations
extérieures sous mandat de l'onu offre
pour le respect du droit international
et assure le maintien de la paix autant
nous refusons de mélanger tous les
conflits en a même souvenir pour les
raisons que je viens d'exposer cet
amalgame risquerait d'ailleurs au fil
des ans doté leur signification aux
autres cérémonies commémoratives et
d'altérer le contenu du nécessaire
devoir de mai du nécessaire devoir de
mémoire qui est aujourd'hui en jeu avec
la disparition des derniers témoins
cette confusion et cette dilution des
mémoire combattante aurait aussi pour
effet d'endormir la vigilance des jeunes
générations pour que ne se répètent pas
les tragédies de l'histoire parce que
nous pensons que ce projet doit recèle
des ans des arrière-pensées de grave
ambiguïté nous ne le voterons pas merci
madame
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur robert tropéano
ainsi le ministre monsieur le président
à mes chers collègues lors novembre 1920
la république française de ramener son
premier hommage au pied de l'arc de
triomphe au soldat inconnu mort pendant
la grande guerre
cette date déclarée chômée commémorative
deux ans plus tard par le parlement et
depuis le point d'orgue de la mémoire
collective française
en effet elle trouve un écho particulier
dans le coeur de nos concitoyens qui
pour beaucoup d'entre eux ont reçu un
héritage de récit de cette guerre qui
n'ont pas connu un valeureux poilus à ce
propos le dernier que nous a quittés le
12 mars 2008
randall encore plus indispensable
l'entretiennent de la flamme du souvenir
la pérennité de l'attachement certains
cas la commémoration du 11 novembre 1918
qui est aussi à l'ampleur du sacrifice
comme n'a consenti par le monde de
combat tag ce sont plus de 70 millions
de soldats provenant de 22 et à
différentes qui se sont engagés dans une
guerre dévastatrice déclaré à l'échelle
du monde
le prix à payer plus lourd 19 millions
de morts et 21 millions de blessés
au sortir de la guerre la douleur fut
timide
non seulement il fallu constater une
perte humaine considérable mais le
témoignage bouleversant des survival
marquera pour toujours les esprits
je citerai le récit anonymes d'employés
qui résume parfaitement ce qu'ils ont
enduré
nous subissons dans la fois toutes les
souffrances toutes les misères toutes
les privations dont les poilus peuvent
être frappés la pluie la boue la glace
la neige l'a fait là soit vrai pour le
bombardement depuis six jours que nous
sommes dans cette tranche et nous
n'avons pas eu la bonne fortune de voir
le soleil un stade le ravitaillement est
devenu à peu près impossible
les hommes qui se rendent dans la nuit à
la corvée de foot revient avec des
boules de pain trempé dans la boue
parfois ils ne reviennent pas du tout
fauché par les obus ou égarés dans les
ténèbres de la nuit
cette évocation qui traduit le sort
commun de tout
génération de feu illustre aussi la
dimension d'unité nationale que revêt
plus que tout autre la guerre de 14 18
c'est pourquoi on peut comprendre le
choix de cette date comme journée
d'hommage aux morts pour la france
civils et militaires pour autant elle ne
doit pas occulter toutes les autres
manifestations commémorant les accidents
de l'histoire
je pense notamment au 8 mai 1945 à la
journée nationale d'hommage aux morts
pour la france en indochine à celle
consacrée aux harkis et bien sûr à
l'hommage aux morts de la guerre
d'algérie et en cette année du
cinquantenaire de la signature des
accords d'evian
je souhaiterais que cette signature des
accords d'evian et cette fin de la
guerre d'algérie soit comme héros d'une
manière particulière je n'oublie pas non
plus toutes les manifestations dédiées
aux victimes d'actes de barbarie je me
réjouis de constater que la commission
des affaires étrangères et de la défense
du sénat a modifié l'article 2 afin de
préciser que l'hommage créé à l'article
1er ne se substituent et pas aux autres
journée de commémoration nationale
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre et
je vous en remercie
cette précision est importante une
majorité d'associations réunis dans un
comité d'entente avait approuvé le
projet de loi initial
mais plusieurs d'entre elles avaient
toutefois craig que cette initiative
attendre à terre une sorte de mémorial
j'ai moi-même partager cette inquiétude
car les stores à sion d'une journée
unique pour est en effet diluer les
enjeux mémoriels propres à chacune des
commémorations qui jalonnent
actuellement le cadre de la grille et
national
cette réserve désormais écarté le groupe
du rdse apportant à ce soutien à ce
projet de loi qui présente un double
intérêt
tout d'abord comme l'a clairement
indiqué notre collègue rapporteur le
dispositif permettra de construire un
lien entre les victimes des différents
conflits
la multiplication au cours de ces
dernières décennies des commémorations
publiques nationales tant la fragmenter
la mémoire collègues
cette nouvelle journée sera l'occasion
d'exprimer la continuité de l'engagement
des générations pour les valeurs les
valeurs intemporelles de liberté et de
fraternité
enfin j'ajouterai que le choix de
célébrer tous les morts de la phrase
permet d'associer tous ceux qui ne sont
actuellement pas représentée par une
journée commémorative
je pense en particulier aux soldats
morts en expo l'opération extérieur ils
sont plus de 6,5
vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
ministre et malheureusement cette liste
s'allonge avec le tag vendredi dernier
en afghanistan
ce sont quatre de nos soldats qui ont
été tuées et ses autres blessés dans la
province de la kapisa
leur courage et leur sens du devoir
méritent toute notre compassion
l'actualité nous rappelle ainsi
tragiquement les dangers encourus par
tous ces combattants dont l'éloignement
géographique ferait presque oublier à
nos concitoyens que des jeunes gens sont
prêts à faire don de leurs vies pour un
idéal de paix universelle
mes chers collègues ce texte est de
nature à donner à donner un nouvel élan
à la politique de commémoration qui doit
rester vive parce qu'elle est un vecteur
essentiel de l'unité nationale est
l'instrument d'une transmission des
valeurs républicaines d'une génération à
l'autre dans une société que bien
d'autres sujet divise le rassemblement
autour d'une mémoire partagée participe
de la cohésion nationale
et j'ajouterais qu'elle demeure
fondamentalement un hommage à tous ceux
qui ont versé leur salle sur l'autel de
la liberté et surtout ils ont versé leur
sac pour défendre les valeurs de la
république
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à madame leila ici
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
jamais je n'avais pensé que de telles
atrocités pouvait se passer dans mon
imagination d'humains ce n'était pas
possible
tout est dit dans ce témoignage du
dernier des tirailleurs sénégalais de la
boucherie que fut la première guerre
mondiale
plus jamais ça ce qu'on est et on au
lendemain du 11 novembre 1918
il est de notre devoir d'obéir à cet
ardent souhait est de perpétuer ce
message pacifiste en commémorant les
morts de la grande guerre
à l'aube du centenaire du déclenchement
du conflit alors que les derniers poilus
nous ont quittés perpétuer le souvenir
de cette atrocité est un impérieux
devoir pour les générations futures
c'est ainsi que pour donner une nouvelle
actualité à la commémoration du 11
novembre
le gouvernement a souhaité qu'à cette
date la nation rendent hommage à tous
les morts pour la france alors que nous
sommes encore sous le choc de la perte
de quatre de nos soldats en afghanistan
les écologistes ne peuvent qu'approuver
un projet de loi commémorant les morts
en opérations extérieures
après tout seul les morts ont vu la fin
de la guerre dit l'adage
le principe du non discrimination des
morts pour la france permettant
d'intégrer ces soldats ayant perdu la
vie en opex est une idée juste des
normes sud ministre monsieur le
président mes chers collègues je voterai
ainsi que l'ensemble du couvre du groupe
par don écologique en faveur de ce
projet de loi
j'aimais cependant quelques réserves sur
le contexte dans lequel nous votons ce
texte réserve monsieur le ministre dont
je ne peut faire l'économie dans cette
discussion à 100 jours de l'élection
présidentielle le caractère
électoraliste de ce projet de loi
n'échappe à personne
pourquoi le gouvernement at il lancé une
procédure accélérée si ce n'était pour
s'assurer les voix des militaires et des
anciens combattants lors des échéances
des mois prochain
cette précipitation du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre pénalise toute la
nation
en effet les lois à caractère historique
joue un rôle capital dans le façonnement
de la mémoire collective
seul un non débat peut être susceptible
d'apporter une réponse à peser à une si
délicate question je me permets
également d'émettre des doutes quant à
l'opportunité du choix de la
as tu du 11 novembre si elle correspond
à la fin de la barbarie à l'élaboration
bien évidemment de projets pacifiste
tels que la construction des sociétés
des nations cette date est aussi celle
de la défaite de l'allemagne défaite que
le traité de versailles a rendu
humiliante
alors que nous souhaitons et oeuvrons
pour une intégration européenne toujours
plus importante et que le couple
franco-allemand nous est si cher la date
du 11 novembre
monsieur le ministre était elle
réellement la plus appropriée pour la
commémoration de nos morts la symbolique
du 8 mai est plus adéquat
elle marque la fin des dictatures nazie
et fasciste mieux encore nous aurions pu
retenir celle du 9 mai je tends les
bases de la construction d'une europe se
fondant sur la paix et la coopération
ces dates possède un effet une charge
émotionnelle beaucoup moins délicieuse
mais là n'est pas mon principal regret
messieurs ministre mon véritable regret
monsieur le ministre est que dans votre
précipitation à faire voter cette loi
vous nous avez preuve priver d'un débat
apaisé sur ce que doit être la
commémoration aujourd'hui
en premier lieu je m'interroge sur les
visages de ces morts pour la france qui
comme berton la grande guerre a aussi
causé la perte de nombreux civils
est-ce qu'on laisse compte parmi les
héros de la nation non ces morts-là
monsieur mini ces victimes innocentes
n'ont pas de monument en instituant le
11 novembre
un hommage à tous les soldats morts pour
la france vous réaffirmer le caractère
militaire de cette commémoration
c'est là un nouveau pas qui nous
éloignent du souvenir des victimes
civiles de la guerre
pourtant ce projet de loi était
l'occasion de repenser notre conception
de la commémoration un débat apaisé
aurait permis de repenser le sens que
nous donnons aux mots héros il est
certain qu'il ne suffit pas d'obéir à la
hiérarchie militaire au sacrifice de sa
vie pour être un héros
les mutins de la grande guerre ont
rejeté l'absurdité la barbarie dans
laquelle la nation se trouvait ils ont
bravé une autorité militaire devenue
absurde
à ce titre il était aussi des héros il
est temps de rendre grâce à ces acteurs
de la paix dont la mémoire a été salie
pour les besoins de l'union sacrée un
débat apaisé nous aurait permis de
reconsidérer la
mémoire de jean jaurès son assassin
raoul villain été acquitté et son procès
elle est toujours au nom de l'union
sacrée l'histoire a donné raison à
jaurès qu'attendons nous pour rétablir
son honneur et reconnaître ce que nous
lui devons
il est certes important de rendre
hommage à tous les morts pour la france
mais nous pouvons nous vivons
aujourd'hui dans un ordre assis sur
l'entente et le droit aussi nous faut-il
rendre hommage à ceux qui font la guerre
à la guerre et aux nouveaux jaurès
acteurs de la paix je pense là aux
travailleurs humanitaires aux
journalistes et aux militants des droits
humains vous nous priver de ce débat
monsieur le ministre mais cela est de
bonne guerre je veux bien admettre que
l'on lorsqu'on se sent menacé par le
vent du changement
il est plus difficile de légiférer
sereinement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'espère seulement que le vent du
changement nous permettra dans quelques
mois d'avoir un débat digne des acteurs
de la paye des enfants de jaurès fut
remerciée merci madame
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur yves detraigne
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
vendredi dernier nous avons encore perdu
quatre de nos soldats en afghanistan
portant ainsi le tribut que la france a
dû verser à la lutte contre le
terrorisme à 82 hommes en dix ans les
guerres change mes chers collègues mais
elle exige toujours le même douloureux
prix du sang le siècle dernier s'est
chargé de nous rappeler cette règle
hélas immuable 4 générations d'hommes et
de femmes ont fait le sacrifice de leur
vie ou jus disparaître leurs proches
il n'y a pas une famille en france qui
ne porte en elle la trace de cette
histoire lazare ponticelli dernier
survivant de la première guerre mondiale
et ancien résistant restera comme l'un
des symboles les plus vibrants de cette
histoire douloureuse qui traverse les
générations
il nous a quittés le 12 mars 2008 à
l'âge de 110 ans après avoir traversé un
siècle de fer rompant ainsi le lien du
témoignage vivant qui nous relier à
l'une des guerres les plus meurtrières
de l'histoire pour autant monsieur
ponticelli ne nous a pas laissés comme
des héritiers son testament sa vie
durant il s'est élevé contre l' oubli
relatif
dans lequel ses compagnons d'armes
avaient pu être plongée n'y a pas que
des soldats inconnus et nous ne sommes
pas redevables qu aux poilus mais aussi
aux soldats de la france libre aux
résistants aux hommes pris au piège de
la cuvette de dien bien phu à ceux qui
sont partis sous l'égide d'un mandat
international défendre notre conception
de la liberté à l'autre bout du monde et
à tant d'autres encore très nombreux
sont nos compatriotes qui sont morts
pour la france
nous avons une dette vis-à-vis d'eux et
il est de notre responsabilité de nous
en a quitté le souvenir et la
reconnaissance sont bien la moindre des
choses que nous pouvions faire à leur
endroit
le présent projet de loi en dépit de son
annonce récente par le président de la
république le 11 novembre dernier est le
fruit d'un long processus de réflexion
et de maturation
il s'agit en effet d'élargir le sens et
la portée de la com
aux rations du 11 novembre consacré
depuis la loi du 24 octobre 1922 aux
soldats de la première guerre mondiale à
l'ensemble de ceux et de celles qui ont
perdu la vie sous les armes au service
de la france et des valeurs dont elle
est porteuse
un tel projet ne repose que formellement
sur une évolution du droit
la commémoration est avant tout un
moment qui nous rassemblent autour d'un
douloureux passé commun le droit
n'instaure pas la mémoire mais il peut
permettre de rassembler la nation dans
un même hommage à tous ceux qui ont
écrit notre histoire de leur sang
la gestation de ce texte a été longue
dès novembre 2008 le président de la
république a confié une mission à
l'historien andré kaspi qui dénonçait je
cite l'inflation commémorative sévissant
depuis une quinzaine d'années avec tous
commémoration officielle par an il
devient de plus en plus complexes de
faire comprendre le sens profond et
commun à chacune de ses manifestations
aux plus jeunes
c'est pourquoi il est important de
redonner du sens à ces commémorations en
accentuant la signification du 11
novembre
c'était là la préoccupation majeure que
j'avais à l'esprit lorsque j'ai voulu
apporter ma contribution à ce débat en
déposant une proposition de loi en ce
sens à l'automne dernier et je tiens
aussi à saluer l'impulsion que notre
collègue jean marie bockel a donné en ce
sens lorsqu'il était membre du
gouvernement
évidemment le droit restera lettre morte
si la tâche n'est pas relayé par les
enseignants qui dans chaque classe
auront à transmettre le devoir de
mémoire du passé qui préside à cette
conception renouvelée du 11 novembre
je pense aux enseignants mais également
aux médias qu'ils devront relier cet
événement de manière à donner à ce jour
la teinte particulière cristallisera la
mémoire de tous ceux qui sont morts pour
la france au delà du simple travail
législatif
il s'agira donc bien de travailler
ensemble enseignants médias mais aussi
nous tous citoyens attachés à notre
histoire
à bâtir une nouvelle forme de
commémoration plus solennelle mais aussi
plus compréhensible pour les jeunes
générations
les sénateurs du groupe de l'union
centriste et républicaine se félicite de
la qualité
les débats que nous avons pu entendre à
l'assemblée nationale comme en
commission
ce projet de loi perdrait beaucoup de
son sens s'il n'avait pas été portée par
un consensus appuyé et construit tout au
long du processus de préparation que
j'ai évoqués précédemment
je tiens aussi à remercier le rapporteur
de notre haute assemblée comme celui de
l'assemblée nationale pour l'esprit de
concorde dans lequel ils ont travaillé
pour toute cette raison pour toutes ces
raisons nous souscrivons à cette
démarche et nous voterons en faveur de
ce projet de loi merci mon cher collègue
la parole était monsieur alain néri
bien
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues au moment où je
prends la parole ici dans la haute
assemblée pour délibérer pour débattre
sur ce projet de loi concernant la
commémoration du 11 novembre
je voudrais avoir une pensée comme vous
tous pour ces quatre soldats français
qui viennent de laisser leur vie en
afghanistan et a envoyé un message de
soutien à leurs familles également à
leurs compagnons d'armes
car lorsqu'un soldats français meurent
si l ensemble de la nation qui est
touché monsieur le ministre nous sommes
d'accord sur l'importance du devoir de
mémoire
même si sa mise en oeuvre soulève
parfois des questions délicates et en
jambes même parfois des débats
difficiles
plus que tout autre sujet la mémoire le
sujet de mémoire doit permettre de se
rassembler se rassembler pour se
souvenir se recueillir et rendre hommage
à tous ceux qui ont sacrifié leur
jeunesse et leur vie pour répondre à
l'appel de la nation et de la république
pour sa défense et le respect sa valeur
dans le respect de ses lois la loi du 24
octobre 1922 appelle à célébrer le 11
novembre
la victoire est là tu es cela
correspondait à une idée qui
correspondait à cette période de notre
histoire
aujourd'hui une autre conception de
l'histoire une autre conception de la
vie permet effectivement d'élargir la
notion de commémoration de recueillement
et de rendre hommage à ceux qui à
l'appel de la nation ont su sacrifier ce
qui leur était le plus cher leur vie et
également leurs familles
le projet de loi que nous avons examinés
visa donc à faire du 11 novembre la date
anniversaire de l'armistice de 1918 une
journée de commémoration pour que les
morts pour la france
nous avons aucune opposition de principe
à ce sujet mais monsieur le ministre
nous sommes obligés de dire que nous
avons été quelque peu surpris par
l'urgence qui a été décrétée par le
gouvernement pour nous amener à débattre
sur ce texte et nous considérons que
cette urgence n'est pas parfaitement
justifiée et que même peut-être elle
peut laisser à penser qu'il y a quelques
idées dans l'esprit de certains qui ne
sont pas tout à fait
decaux la commémoration et l'hommage
rendu à l'ensemble des combattants
en effet des voies diverses et variées
s'élèvent parfois ici aulas pour
dénoncer le trop grand nombre de
manifestations commémoratives
il a même été créé en 2008 une com est
une commission spéciale la commission
kaspi pour faire des propositions en ce
sens mais les conclusions de cette
commission kaspi ne vise en aucune façon
à privilégier une seule date pour que on
soit dans la situation d'avoir une date
unique de commémoration un mémorial des
en quelque sorte à la française encore
que si on prend la peine de regarder les
choses de plus près aux états unis et
nous ne sommes pas obligés de copier nos
amis américains parce qu'ils ont leurs
traditions et nous avons les nôtres mais
à côté du memorial day n'oublions pas
qu'aux états unis
il y a aussi le veteran's day donc nous
sommes attachés à une date spécifique
pour chacun des conflits le rapport
kaspi proposé de privilégier trois dates
le 14 juillet le 8 mai et le 11 novembre
il est impensable pour nous d'accepter
un jour de commémoration unique pour
toutes les guerres et que leurs
combattants qui reviendrait à quelque
sorte
à banaliser voire à diluer la mémoire
chaque conflit a sa spécificité
ses causes et ses conséquences et c'est
pourquoi c'est pourquoi chacune des
générations du feu a droit à une journée
historique et symbolique de
reconnaissance de la nation occasion
d'une leçon d'instruction civique et de
renforcer la cohésion nationale c'est
date de commémoration doivent être
effectivement le moment privilégié
sûrement à l'école de faire le devoir de
mémoire de faire passer le message aux
jeunes générations mais aussi mes chers
collègues dans les familles et je crois
que chaque perte famille chaque grand
père et pourquoi pas grand mère ou ma
famille et chaque chacun d'entre nous
peut être saisir l'occasion des
manifestations au monument aux morts
pour prendre un enfant par la main et
l'amener au monument aux morts en lui
expliquant les raisons
les causes les conséquences du conflit
et pourquoi nous sommes rassemblés
devant les monuments nos communes en ces
occasions là voici monsieur le ministre
certainement une des raisons de voir
évoluer
l'évocation du 11 novembre mais
convenait que lorsque vous avez dit il
s'agit d'engager le processus pour fêter
le centenaire de 14 18
convenez avec moi que nous avions quand
même un peu de temps puisque 1914 pour
avoir 100 ans ça sera 2014 et que si
c'est pour se rappeler de l'armistice
s'étaient le 11 novembre 1918 et donc le
centenaire sera le 11 novembre 2018 ce
qui convenons-en nous c nous laisser un
peu de temps pour mener ensemble une
réflexion approfondie
sur les nouvelles façons de commémorer
et d'engager effectivement le renouveau
le renouvellement un nouvel élan pour le
devoir de mémoire
d'autant plus que mon inquiétude
monsieur le ministre c'est quand vous
avez dit le dernier poilu a disparu
alors le dernier poilu français en 2008
vous avez fait remarquer que le dernier
poilu australien assez terne 2011 est
effectivement que cette guerre avait été
une guerre mondiale une affreuse
boucherie que personne ne pouvait
envisager un tel degré d'horreur encore
que la guerre 39-45 dans ce domaine là
n'avaient rien à envier à la précédente
alors monsieur le ministre comme la
démographie fait son oeuvre
il est vrai qu'à plus de poilus de 14 18
mai devant nos monuments aux morts
il arrive que nous n'ayons plus dans nos
villages d'anciens combattants de 39 45
alors alors me revient en mémoire
douloureusement la suppression de la
commémoration du 8 mai 1945 par un
président de la république qui était de
ma région
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing et
qu'il a fallu que françois mitterrand
lorsqu'il a été élu premier république
rétablisse les anciens combattants 39 45
et les résistants dans leur droit à une
juste reconnaissance de leurs sacrifices
et de leur réponse à l'appel de la
nation pour rétablir la république qui
avait été supprimé alors pour toutes ces
raisons nous avions hésité
monsieur le ministre à voter votre texte
et je mens était ouvert à monsieur le
rapporteur de gens dont je à qui je
tiens à rendre hommage car par son
ouverture d'esprit et par la vôtre aussi
monsieur le ministre vous avez bien
voulu accepter de prendre en contre le
l'amendement que j'ai déposé au nom du
groupe socialiste pour dire que
il fallait préciser vous nous le disiez
et je voulais dit je vous fais pas de
procès d'intention dans votre esprit
peut-être que vous n'envisagiez pas de
supprimer une date de date pour en
laisser qu'une mais vous savez on nous
sommes de passage et d'autres mal
intentionné aurait pu être saisie de la
volonté de nous imposer une date unique
que nous refusons et que l'ensemble des
combattants refuse au nom du juste droit
à une commémoration de chacun d'entre
eux alors nous avons déposé d'amendement
qui était avant tout un amendement de
garantie d'assurance de précaution et
cet amendement après discussion la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense de notre assemblée en accord
avec le rapporteur est avec vous mais
monsieur le ministre nous sommes arrivés
à rédiger un amendement qui est un
amendement qui a été votée à l'unanimité
des membres de la commission
et c'est pourquoi nous considérons
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons obtenu les
garanties pour que le 11 novembre
effectivement un fort moment de
commémoration exclusif d'aucun autre
moment de prise en compte du devoir de
mémoire de recueillement et de rendre
hommage à tous ceux qui ont répondu à
l'appel de la nation et de la patrie
pour défendre les valeurs de la
république
c'est pourquoi dans un souci d'unité
nationale nous voterons ce texte
féministe
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur pierre charon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la semaine dernière la france a perdu
quatre soldats
j'ai reçu la dépêche alors que je
préparais ce texte
et croyez moi chacun des mots qui le
composent a été accompagné par l'émotion
et par la consternation face à cet
assassinat de la part de terroristes
dont le cynisme n'a d'égal que la
lâcheté
pour commencer je viens bien sûr à
témoigner à nos soldats à leur famille
et à leurs compagnons d'armes la plus
sincère affliction et mon plus profond
respect nous connaissons leur
professionnalisme leur engagement et
leur courage sur le sol national ou en
opex à des milliers de kilomètres ils
sont la fierté de notre pays c'est pour
chacun de ces hommes tombés au combat et
pour ceux qui ne reviennent jamais un
thème que nous nous réunissons
aujourd'hui afin de tisser le souvenir
de leur engagement avec la mémoire de la
france
je formule le voeu que cette mémoire
soit vivante et quotidiennes depuis 2007
grâce à l'impulsion donnée par le chef
de l'état les rendez vous de notre pays
avec son histoire ont été revitalisé et
sont chaque année l'occasion de vivifier
notre passé qu'ils soient glorieux ou
douloureux dans cette perspective le
président de la république a souhaité
faire du 11 novembre jour de mémoire de
tous les morts pour la france
à cet égard je souhaite rendre un
hommage particulier à notre rapporteur
marcel pierre cléach qui sur ce projet
de loi mme comme pour celui relatif à
l'indemnisation des victimes des essais
nucléaires français à sucre et les
justes conditions législatives envers
ceux qui ont servi hier la république
ce projet doit attirer la bienveillance
de chacun d'entre nous les morts ne sont
pas ceux de gauche ou de ceux de la
droite ils sont les morts de la france
c'est donc collectivement et dont le
silence des querelles politiciennes que
nous leur devons honneur et respect
donné sa vie pour protéger sa patrice
la rencontre de l'humilité et de la
gloire ces dernières années notamment du
fait de l'envoi de nos troupes en
afghanistan mais pas seulement
notre pays a dû réapprendre ce qu'était
la spécificité de l'engagement militaire
cela parce que les français ont la
chance de vivre en paix sur le sol
national
et l'on entrevue le phénomène de guerre
et le prix de 800 cas travers les médias
cette paix si précieuse si douce a
pourtant un ennemi l'oubli il est bon
que nous ayons ce lien douloureux entre
les morts de la guerre et l'existence
même de notre nation existence de nos
villes de nos territoires de notre
civilisation et de nos frontières
la france a plus que jamais besoin de se
retrouver avec elle même de toucher ce
lien sacré qui dans l'histoire en fonte
et des miracles d'inspiration de
dévouement et d'héroïsme honneur à vous
soldats morts pour la france
à verdun ou à kapissa honneur à vous qui
reposaient dans la mémoire des siècles
honneur à vous qui avez mis votre vie au
service de la paix les législateurs que
nous sommes avons le devoir d'entretenir
cette chaîne du souvenir qui réunit les
morts d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
nous avons la responsabilité de créer
les conditions d'une union et de
rassemblements pour que nos concitoyens
puissent leur témoigner la
reconnaissance de la nation entière
nous avons le devoir de porter leur
mémoire avec fierté et avec grandeur
cette date doit devenir le socle
solennelle de se souvenir
elle doit rassembler la nation dans
l'épreuve autour de valeurs et de codes
qui sont les fondements de notre
république
il ne s'agit pas bien sûr de
hiérarchiser les commémorations pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'on ne
hiérarchise pas les morts comme le
soulignait le président de la république
quel que soit le lieu quel que soit le
moment de notre histoire ce don est
sacré et il mérite le même hommage la
même reconnaissance la même ferveur
la mort au service de la france ne fait
pas de différence
le champ d'honneur et de toutes les
guerres et de tous les conflits compte
impliquer notre pays le choix de réunir
la célébration de tous les morts pour la
france le même jour permet de nous lier
aucun à ce titre le choix de la date du
11 novembre me semble adéquat pour
plusieurs raisons tout d'abord pour ne
pas alourdir le calendrier commémoratif
dont le nombre de dates a doublé depuis
10 ans ensuite car au delà de commémorer
l'armistice qui mit fin aux souffrances
de la grande guerre le 11 novembre
représente le sacrifice consenti pour
une nation qui représentait non
seulement son territoire mais surtout
l'union d'un peuple autour des principes
indéfectible de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité
quel meilleur symbole que celui pour
abriter aux morts quel plus grande
solennité pour honorer la mémoire de
chacun de ces hommes tombés au combat
quel plus beau rendez-vous que celui de
la paix et du peuple pour célébrer le
lien charnel de la patrie et de son
armée c'est sans doute cette évidence
qui a amené le projet de loi être votée
à l'unanimité par là commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées présidé par jean louis
carrère et qui donnent aujourd'hui toute
sa ferveur au groupe ump pour voter en
faveur de ce texte je finirai avec
quelques mots de lamartine en
récapitulant toutes ses passions
instinctive dont se compose pour nous
l'amour de la patrie et on y ajoute
encore une passion nature et la lhomme
la passion de sa propre mémoire de la
gloire de la postérité et du dévouement
jusqu'à la mort pour son pays
on comprend que s'il ya dans l'histoire
des efforts surnaturel attendre de
l'humanité il faut les attendre du
patriotisme
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
dans la suite des discussions générales
la marolle est à monsieur andré trillard
jaloux
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à l'instar
de mes collègues je tiens à rendre un
hommage appuyé solennel à la mémoire des
quatre soldats disparus vendredi dernier
il y associer leurs familles leurs
proches leurs camarades et là toute la
communauté du monde combattant
évoquant les combattants d'hier et leurs
descendants
m'adressant à ceux d'aujourd'hui et de
demain je veux saisir l'occasion qui
m'est donnée pour leur témoigner notre
attachement leur exprimer le grand
respect et la profonde admiration qui
nous aspire dans cet hémicycle nous
n'avons que trop rarement l'occasion de
nous livrer à une vraie réflexion sur le
monde combattant sur ces acteurs
militaires et civils et sur le rôle
essentiel au sein de notre société en
quête de repères et dont les valeurs
traditionnelles sont souvent malmené
aussi à cette tribune je veux saluer
tout particulièrement les associations
et les responsabilités qu'elle assume
car l'examen de ce projet de loi est une
occasion de rappeler leur rôle
fondamental dans l'entretien et la
transmission de notre mémoire nationale
à toute une société civile aujourd'hui
souvent éloignés des réalités militaires
peu conscients du lien fort entre
l'armée et la nation voire sujette à un
certain d'antimilitarisme quoi qu'il en
soit nos associations son quotidien le
relais indispensable du rendre honneur
et du savoir commémoré par leurs actions
elle participe à l'ancrage indispensable
dans les esprits d'un triste war de nos
valeurs et de nos idéaux
et c'est au plus profond d'un territoire
cet après midi je salue l'adoption en
commission à l'unanimité ce projet de
loi promet ainsi donné que le devoir de
mémoire envers ce que se sont sacrifiés
pour la république dépasse les clivages
les questions de mémoire ne sont
l'apanage d'aucun parti ni d'aucun
groupe ce dont nous pouvons être
collectivement fier
si la date du 11 novembre semblait
s'imposer d'elle-même je me félicite que
notre rapporteur est acceptée dans sa
grande sagesse
un amendement précisant que cette date
ne se substituerait pas aux autres
commémorations
l'article 2 permet l'inscription des
noms de nos braves sur les monuments aux
morts
mais encore faut-il créer les conditions
du rassemblement de la nation autour de
ces monuments et autour de leurs frères
d'armes et cela ne peut se faire sans
pédagogie sans l'éducation des jeunes
générations le savoir comme et murray ne
peut pas reposer sur le seul relais
associatifs ou sur la seule journée du
citoyen il doit passer d'abord par
l'école de la république et par un
projet mémorielle collectif il en va de
la pérennité d'un vrai esprit de défense
et le témoignage de notre patriotisme
pour pierre meurent à la commémoration
est l'expression concentré d'une
histoire nationale
un moment rare et céliane selon m rien
n'est plus vrai mais les législateurs
que nous sommes doivent aller au delà je
n'en doute pas au delà mais pas trop
c'est pour cette raison que je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur un point
précis
depuis la fin du service militaire notre
armée koné a turn over nécessaires aux
nouveaux besoins opérationnels
bon nombre de jeunes qui auront commencé
une carrière mais retourneront à la vie
à la vie civile ces soldats sont de
futurs jeunes vétérans beaucoup d'entre
eux qui rentrent d'opex à une certaine
indifférence et parfois la compréhension
d'une société pour qui le don de soi
pour la patrie n'est pas une évidence
pourtant ces vétérans d'un genre nouveau
sont les ambassadeurs de valeur
inestimable tels que le dépassement de
soi le courage la discipline
de la même façon que la nation va rendre
un hommage collectif ceux qui sont
tombés au champ d'honneur
elle ne doit oublier ni abandonner ceux
qui en reviennent parfois marqués
psychologiquement ou physiquement à vie
à cet instant je pense aux soldats
hospitalisés à l'hôpital percy
dans le même esprit
et ni mon propos est tous ceux qui sont
rentrés du liban de côte d'ivoire du
kosovo et d'afghanistan
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
dans la suie discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur ronan kerdraon
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire d'état monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous sommes donc
réunis cet après-midi pour débattre du
texte fixant au 11 novembre la date de
commémoration de tous les morts pour la
france et alain néri notre orateur
principal l'a très bien annoncé tout à
l'heure nous voterons ce texte
pour autant ce texte qui fait suite au
discours du président de la république
le 11 novembre dernier suscite quelques
interrogations et j'en ai relevé au
moins quatre premières interrogations
pourquoi engager la procédure accélérée
sur un tel texte
d'autres sujets de titres il pas plus
urgent dans le contexte actuel ne
faut-il pas y déceler l'arrière-pensée
d'en tirer quelques bénéfices électorale
d'ici 90 jours
deuxième interrogation pourquoi choisir
le 11 novembre n'existe aucune autre
possibilité de trouver une date
spécifique est plus approprié troisième
interrogation
le président de la république ne
s'engage t-il pas sur la voie
aventureuse d'une amérique il une
américanisation du 11 novembre et donc
d'une sorte de moeurs de memorial day
qui ne dit pas son nom
4e interrogations aux fins ne
craignez-vous pas par cette confusion
mémorielle de légitimer les guerres
impérialistes menée par la france
certes depuis plus de 20 ans notre pays
se trouvent engagés sont de multiples
théâtres d'opérations extérieures le
liban l'ex yougoslavie l'afghanistan
beaucoup de soldats trop bien sûr 100
morts depuis la fin de la guerre
d'algérie
ce sont plus de 600 militaires et encore
4 on l'a dit en fin de semaine dernière
leur sacrifice mérite respect et
reconnaissance de la part de la nation
toute entière
mais ma conviction est que ces
engagements n'ont pas la même portée
historique humaine
et géopolitique que la grande guerre
l'ampleur inégalée du drame qu'a
représenté pour la france la première
guerre mondiale justifierait s'il en
était besoin que soit garder sa
spécificité à la cérémonie du 11
novembre
aussi le 11 novembre et du reste et
l'évocation de cette terrible carnage
qui a fait plus de 10 millions de morts
que nous avons connu presque toutes les
familles ont été touchées
souvenons nous des écrits pour la france
2 rue barbusse pour l'allemagne
d'heinrich mari harry marque le 11
novembre aurait dû rester le rappel des
ravages des nationalismes d esprit de
revanche et des haines entretenu pour de
mauvaises causes par ailleurs la
première guerre mondiale marque
véritablement l'entrée dans le xxème
siècle la carte de l'europe a été
redessinée par le traité de versailles
les empires allemand austro-hongrois et
russes ont disparu des alliances se sont
nouées de nouveaux états ont vu le jour
et bien évidemment la société des
nations a été créé en outre monsieur le
secrétaire d'état si ce texte venait à
être adoptée sans la garantie de
maintenir les autres dates mémorial dont
le 8 mai il viendrait en contradiction
avec les efforts que nous faisons nous
les élus dans nos communes au sujet de
la première guerre mondiale mais aussi
de la deuxième de la résistance de la
libération ou encore de la déportation
n'est-il n'était il pas plus urgent de
revenir sur les réformes des programmes
d'histoire ayant conduit depuis 2009 un
appauvrissement et un affaiblissement
inquiétant de cet enseignement qui
demeure pourtant l'un des meilleur
rempart contre les dérives de toutes
natures
pour autant nous sommes également
persuadé qu'un hommage spécifique doit
être rendu aux soldats morts ou blessés
en opérations extérieures
c'est pourquoi nous regrettons que leur
mémoire n'est pas fait l'objet d'une
véritable réflexe réflexion approfondie
ma collègue l'a dit tout à l'heure et
d'un véritable débat non seulement avec
les associations patriotiques avec les
élus
mais aussi avec les enseignants
toutefois je ne crois pas que cela
puisse se faire au détriment de la
réalité historique de la confusion et de
la mémoire d'un conflit dont il ne reste
plus aujourd'hui de témoins je suis
intimement persuadé que le souvenir et
le sens des conflits ne doivent pas
s'effacer avec la disparition des
combattants par ailleurs j'ai constaté
dans mon département dans ma commune que
l'idée de commémorer l'ensemble des
morts pour la france a une seule date
est loin de faire consensus
mais monsieur le secrétaire d'état vous
voulez nous rassurez vous nous avez
rassuré sur le fait qu'aucune
commémoration ne serait supprimé nous en
prenons acte
cela étant nous préférons l'inscrire
parce que nous savons ce qu'il en est
des engagements de votre gouvernement et
du président de la république ce
quinquennat a été marqué par une longue
suite de reniement nous n'avons pas nous
à écrire une histoire officielle par
contre un double constat unanime peu à
mon sens être fait c'est celui du peu
d'appétence de nos concitoyens pour les
commémorations et un sens de ces
dernières quelque peu brouillé dès lors
quel rôle doit jouer le parlement dans
les commémorations et de fait quelle
place tiennent tel dans la nation sont
elles utiles indispensable
faut-il en supprimer ou en choisir
d'autres quelles sont les valeurs à
inclure dans ces commémorations
à cette dernière question je fais mienne
la position adoptée par andré kaspi qui
a affirmé que les valeurs inclus repose
sur trois piliers
je cite les valeurs républicaines d'une
part liberté égalité fraternité
démocratie les valeurs patriotiques
héroïsme sacrifice indépendance
nationale paie et engagements et les
valeurs sociales adhésion à la nation
réhabilitation des victimes respect et
citoyenneté je pense que le test que
vous nous proposez aujourd'hui est
malheureusement loin de répondre à ces
questions à toutes ces questions et
surtout neutre est le véritable sujet
que par un prisme certes indispensable
mais réducteur pour autant et en
conclusion si l'amendement déposé par
notre collègue alain néri au nom de
notre groupe garantit le maintien des
dates mémorielle existantes
nous approuvons ses textes merci merci
mon cher collègue de parole est un
monsieur bruno retailleau
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
les français sont un peuple nous sommes
un peuple paradoxal puisque il y a dans
notre pays
ça vient d'être souligné beaucoup
beaucoup de commémoration et en même
temps parfois nous avons tendance à
cultiver l'auto dénigrement et même
parfois la repentance je crois que
derrière ce paradoxe apparent il y à une
réalité c'est l'attachement des français
à leur histoire l'attachement des
français à leur pays l'attachement des
français à leur identité
monsieur le ministre il ya quelques
jours nous avons vous et moi été le
témoin de cet attachement puisque vous
êtes déplacé pour fêter le 60ème
anniversaire d'un grand soldat français
dans un petit village vendéen ce grand
soldat c'est jean de lattre de tassigny
ce village c'est mouilleron le captif où
est né à la fois jean de lattre de
tassigny georges clemenceau qui fut
comme vous le savez chers collègues
aussi sénateur mais je crois que cet
attachement qui est profond et on l'a
bien vu puisque malgré l'heure matinale
malgré la froidure du moment il ya eu
plus de 1000 personnes qui se sont
déplacées qui ont voulu absolument
témoigner leur propre attachement et
elles ont voulu ces personnes je crois
témoigné une reconnaissance une
gratitude vis-à-vis de ce grand soldat
de vis-à-vis tous les soldats morts pour
la france je n'en doute pas dans des
circonstances un peu dramatique et je
crois que ce souvenir les habitait et je
pense que aujourd'hui ce que nous allons
faire en votant tous ensemble ce texte
c'est une belle oeuvre parce que je
pense que ce texte répond à un triple au
devoir de mémoire bien sûr d'unités mais
surtout surtout de transmission pour les
nouvelles générations
le devoir de mémoire il a souvent été
soulignée je crois que c'est une
question de justice
c'est une question aussi de civilisation
la justice et les pour tous les morts
pour la france
quelle que soit la génération du feu
bien entendu combattre l'oubli c'est
combattre une injustice c'est finalement
si nous oublions nos morts pour la
france
et bien leur donner une deuxième mort
dans cet espace symbolique de la mémoire
et au moment où l'histoire se raccourcit
souvent dramatiquement dans l'actualité
à une époque où l'instant gouverne tout
et et surtout l'histoire longue
je pense que c'est important d'en créer
dans un jour particulier cet effort qui
doit être un effort qui rassembla
communauté nationale
c'est donc je pense d'abord une question
d'injustice et de justice donc est aussi
une question de civilisation parce que
il n'ya pas de civilisation sans mémoire
les sociétés sans mémoire sont des
sociétés barbare et je crois que on a
commis une erreur fatale finalement de
penser que le devoir de mémoire
concernait le passé non je pense que le
2 vers le devoir de mémoire concerne
tout au contraire l'avenir c'est le sens
je crois d'une phrase qui a écrit un
jour dans un de ses romans dans un de
ses très beaux romans dostoïevski
lorsqu'ils disaient les peuple sans
mémoire sont condamnés à mourir de froid
le devoir de mémoire mais surtout le
devoir d'unité
il y avait ce cher collègue une leçon
française une leçon française contes
illustrés à leur manière
clemenceau avec l'union sacrée de lattre
de tassigny avec l' amalgame à partir de
résistants et de soldats professionnels
pour composer la première rame mais
c'est tout simplement
et bien sûr la résistance française est
bien sûr aussi ceux qui sont tombés dans
les rizières de l'oubli ou du djebel et
qui tombe aujourd'hui encore en
afghanistan chers collègues pour
défendre nos valeurs qui sont les
valeurs de la france et la verdeur de la
république on est bien d'accord on est
tout à fait d'accord mais ce que je veux
dire
surtout c'est que cette unité nationale
elle est aussi une unité autour de la
mémoire et je pense que nous avons
encore besoin
1 face à l'adversité aujourd'hui
économique
hier peut être militaire mais nous en
avons d'autant plus besoin que notre
tissu social est aujourd'hui déchirée
par le haut et par le bas par le bas par
l'hyper individualisme qui considère que
la collectivité où l'individu retire
toute la collectivité que finalement il
ne doit rien à la collectivité
l'individualisme d'un côté et aussi le
communautarisme mais je pense que et
vous en conviendrez
je pense que la france n'a jamais été
une rencontre de hasard je pense que la
france est beaucoup plus qu'une
juxtaposition d'individus et c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus mes chers
collègues qu un archipel de tribus ou qu
un archipel de communiquer d'une
communauté je pense que s'associer tous
ensemble sur ce texte pour reconnaître
une seule et même au noir pour tous les
combattants français
je pense que c'est faire oeuvre monsieur
ministre d'unités la troisième le
troisième de voir c'est le devoir qui
concerne l'avenir un devoir qui concerne
la transmission
parce que je pense que la mémoire ne
doit pas être une mémoire tourné vers le
passé ça doit être une mémoire mes chers
collègues vivante et la transmission est
aussi essentiel que le devoir en
lui-même de commémoration un devoir de
mémoire bien sûr et de ce point de vue
là je pense que ce texte sera positif
s'il encourage un effort de pédagogie
cela a été dit il ya quelques instants
dans les écoles vis-à-vis des jeunes
générations c'est fondamental peut-être
pour leur dire que l'amour de la france
est positif est que comme disait romain
gary faut distinguer de patriotisme et
le nationalisme le patriotisme c'est
l'amour des siens
le nationalisme c'est la haine des
autres peut-être aussi pour les
encourager au civisme
peut-il y avoir aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues y compris dans la
mondialisation dans ce monde aplati
peut-il y avoir une société une
civilisation une cité qui tiennent
debout sans civisme le civis c'est le
courage d'enseigner à nos enfants que un
jour il faut être capable de donner au
pays autant qu'on a reçu de lui
monsieur le ministre votre texte nous
parle des valeurs de la république de la
france qui sont des valeurs éternelles
pour lesquelles des français meurent
encore y compris à l'étranger pour les
défendre
en parlant de ces valeurs qui sont de
grande valeur qui nous tiennent tous au
coeur où que nous soyons sûrs c'est bon
je pense qu'il nous parle aussi des
raisons d'aujourd'hui et de demain qu'on
les français à vivre encore ensemble
merci merci mon cher collègue la
discussion générale et claude se
munissent vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les dessinateurs d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier pour ce débat je
pense que c'est un débat qui honore nous
a semblé aussi bien à l'assemblée
nationale qu ici au sénat je pense que
ça a été de très haute tenue et ça
montre notre attachement que nous avons
tous un autre pays et tout à l'heure
bruno retailleau il ya quelques minutes
parler de patriotisme et nationalisme
mais je crois que par ce n'est pas nous
avons montré tous les uns les autres
le patriotisme qui était le nôtre et les
valeurs auxquelles nous sommes tous
attachés qu'ils sont les valeurs de
notre république de notre nation et je
crois que c'est très important je
voulais remercier le rapporteur pour son
excellent rapport dire que je crois que
j'ai essayé aussi dans le débat dans les
expressions que j'ai eue de montrer que
peut-être les inquiétudes que vous
pouviez avoir n'était pas fondée je
pense que le débat de savoir s'il
y'avait suppression n'y a jamais été
question de faire un mémorial des il n'a
jamais été question de supprimer les
autres dates il n'y a jamais été
question de faire une hiérarchie dans
ces dates
bien entendu et bien toutes les autres
dates continueront à être fêté et c'est
normal et à commémorer et je crois que
c'est tout à fait normal
bien entendu de continuer à le faire
vous avez suivi le début de l'examen du
projet de loi faisant du 11 novembre la
journée de commémoration de tous les
morts pour la france dans quelques
instants c'est l'heure de preuves par 3
qui reçoit jean marie le pen le
président d'honneur du front national a
très bonne soirée à tous sur public
sénat